the nobel prize for medicine goes to
three biochemists who live and work in
the united states
the nobel assembly at kerlinski
institute has today decided to award the
2013 nobel prize in physiology or
medicine
jointly
to james rothman randy schechtman and
thomas hudov
how do cells in the body transport
molecules like insulin what jeans and
markers ensure that these substances
arrive at the right place at the right
time
decades of research enabled the three
scientists to answer those fundamental
questions german-born thomas sudhof is a
professor at stanford university he
hails from gutingen and has been working
in the united states for 30 years
james rothman researches at yale
and randy shekman is at the university
of california at berkeley the call from
sweden woke him in the middle of the
night
hello i didn't even have a chance to
look at the clock to see when it was
and uh picked up the phone and this very
distinctive swedish accent of goron
hansen who's the chairman of the
medicine prize committee called
and he
congratulated me he assured me that this
was not a hoax
implications the three winners will
receive their prize at a ceremony in
stockholm on december 10th and they'll
share the purse of almost 1 million
euros